شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
ظبي رائعة للجولف
وأعتقد أنها نمت بالفعل على مدار
العشرين عامًا الماضية، إنها بالتأكيد
وجهة سياحية للاعبي الجولف من جميع المستويات
للتدريب والمنافسة ولعب
تجربة رائعة للجميع، إنه أمر مثير
بالنسبة لي كمواطن إماراتي  لاعب
لديه تلك الفرص
[تصفيق]
وهذا هو غزلان أبو ظبي
[موسيقى]
والغولف ليس الاقتران الأكثر وضوحًا
ولكن هذا ما يجذب لاعب الجولف المحترف
الأول والوحيد في الإمارات العربية المتحدة إلى الملعب
في جزيرة الساديات. ما أحبه في
الساديات وما الذي  يفصله بالنسبة لي عن
أي نادي جولف آخر إلى جانب أن
الجولف المذهل هو مجرد الحيوانات
الموجودة في ملعب الجولف
[موسيقى]
بالنسبة لي كوني من محبي الحيوانات، من
المدهش أن آتي إلى هنا وأرى
الغزلان والصقور والأنواع المختلفة
الحيوانات هي مجرد شيء
أستمتع به
بعد أن أضربت لعبة الجولف فقط لأنظر
حولي وأرى كل هذه
الحيوانات الرائعة كانت مذهلة للغاية
ومريحة للغاية وأنا أستمتع بها في كل
مرة آتي إلى هنا
منذ أن أصبحت محترفًا في عام 2012، لقد
لعب أحمد  يتنافس العالم في ما يصل
إلى 25 بطولة سنويًا مع بداية
تقويم Pro Golf على أرض الوطن،
يبدأ العام في أبو ظبي في البداية، كما
تعلم مع بطولة HSBC
التي يتم لعبها في ياسلينكس ثم
لدينا بطولة دبي ديزرت كلاسيك وبعدها
راسوتشيما لفريق الروك تشامبس والذي
يطلق عليه في نهاية المطاف أرجوحة الصحراء هنا
في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة، بالطبع نحن فخورون جدًا
بأبو ظبي لتولي هذا
الدور الرائد في لعبة الجولف،
وخاصة
ليس فقط إقامة فعاليات جولة P ولكن
أيضًا أحداث جولة التحدي
عادت جولة التحدي إلى المملكة المتحدة الإمارات العربية المتحدة لأول
مرة منذ خمس سنوات مع
تحدي أبوظبي الذي أقيم في
نادي أبوظبي الشهير للغولف، يليه
تحدي الإمارات العربية المتحدة في جزيرة الساديات،
ملعب الجولف الذي صممته
لاعبة هو ملعب للبطولات
يحتوي على بعض  من أفضل اللاعبين في
العالم يأتون إلى هنا، بعض
لاعبي الجولات الأوروبية يأتون إلى هنا
ويشاركون أيضًا،
ملعب جولف رائع للتواجد فيه، لدينا
67 مخبأ هنا، الدورة
صعبة للغاية، الظروف هنا
صعبة للغاية لأننا وصلنا إلى هناك  الشاطئ لذا
يمكن أن يكون الجو عاصفًا جدًا، وكذلك طول
ملعب الجولف، والمخابئ التي تعرفها
المخاطر الموجودة هناك،
والمياه، والمحيط يمثل تحديًا كبيرًا
للاعبين من جميع المستويات بما فيهم أنا،
ويستقبل نادي شاطئ سادياد للغولف في
المتوسط ​​40 لاعبًا  000 زائر محلي ودولي
سنويًا يستمتعون
بالممرات الـ 72 الماضية في أبوظبي، وهو ما
يعني باللغة العربية والد
الغزال، إنها بالتأكيد
وجهة سياحية للاعبي الغولف من جميع
المستويات ولدي أصدقاء من حياتي
يأتون إلى هنا و  الرغبة في تجربة
ليس فقط جزء الجولف في أبو ظبي
والساديات ولكن جميع الأنشطة الرائعة الأخرى
التي توفرها المدينة
منحنيات آسرة من كل زاوية،
ثماني طبقات من الألومنيوم والفولاذ
تخلق أنعم الضوء
مع المباني المكعبة البيضاء المتواضعة، متحف
اللوفر أبو  أبوظبي عبارة عن لوحة قماشية بيضاء
من الخارج،
هذا المكان مذهل،
هناك بعض التاريخ الرائع من جميع
القارات في جميع أنحاء العالم سواء
كان أوروبيًا في الخليج أو آسيويًا في
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية أيضًا،
لذلك هناك مجموعة كبيرة ومتنوعة من الأشياء التي
يمكنني استكشافها  كشخص، وهذا
شيء سأتطلع إليه دائمًا،
ولم أستكشف المكان بأكمله بعد
لأنه ضخم جدًا،
الزقاق مستوحى من المدينة المنورة،
يكشف عن أعمال فنية في كل زاوية
تؤدي إلى الفناء الرئيسي،
الهندسة المعمارية، المكان للغاية
إنه شيء جميل لم أره من قبل
وأعتقد أن هذا هو السبب وراء
اهتمام الناس به كثيرًا.
ليست القطع
الفنية التاريخية في الداخل هي التي تجتذب حشودًا كبيرة فحسب، بل أيضًا
السلاحف البحرية التي ينقذها المقيمون
والتي يزيد عمر بعضها عن 200 عام.
بحيرة المتحف هي المحطة الأخيرة
للسلاحف قبل أن يطلقها حوض السمك الوطني
مرة أخرى إلى المحيط مع
أجهزة التتبع لمراقبة تقدمها،
إنه مكان رائع للابتعاد
عن الخليج، إنه مكان مريح بالنسبة
لي،
يمكن أن يكون الجولف مرهقًا للغاية
في بعض الأحيان، كما تعلمون، وإذا لم ألعب بأفضل ما
لدي، فمن الجيد أحيانًا الابتعاد
عن ذلك واستكشاف
أشياء مختلفة وأعتقد أن هذا هو بالتأكيد
مكان سأعود إليه وأتعلم المزيد
عن هذا، إنه أبو ظبي الخاص بي،
شكرًا لكم.